good evening ladies and gentlemen my
name is Alan Bernstein I'm the president
and CEO of CFR the canadian institutes
for Advanced Research welcome tonight's
CFR knowledge circle event on why
nations fail generously supported and
presented by scotiabank my sincerest
thanks to Rick Waugh and his team is
scotiabank for making this night
possible if you google why nations fail
which I did this afternoon you'll get
about 35 million hits that's a lot of
hits and why is that I think there's at
least three reasons first I think all of
us want to live in a society that's
successful successful as defined as safe
successful as the in terms of our
standard of living opportunities for our
children fairness openness and
democratic second the world I think is
going through an exceptionally troubling
an uncertain time economically and
politically but also troubling
considering the Gulf and the widening
gulf between rich and poor rich and poor
nations between Western and Islamic
countries and culture the North and the
South etc and third the book itself is a
compelling enjoyable closely argued read
although it is a lot of pages I don't
know who your editor was thrown and it
seeks to answer the question important
question why are some countries
successful and others not these are the
sorts of questions that see far is all
about from early childhood learning to
the origins and evolution of our
universe and our planet to the
biological underpinnings of health and
disease for over 30 years see far has
been bringing together some of the most
extraordinary minds on this planet to
address these and other important
pressing and exciting questions with the
absolute conviction
that the first step to solving and
answering these questions is to
understand them and understanding leads
to solutions the book why nations fail
has been reviewed by essentially every
every major publication on earth let me
just give you a small part of one quote
from The Wall Street Journal why nations
fail is a vital work for these times it
is an eloquent and powerful statement
and it goes on and yesterday my former
boss Bill Gates who rarely comments on
books I think he reads them but he
rarely comments on the publicly had a
blog two days ago on the book and Darren
and I were discussing what he had to say
maybe he'll talk about it in his remarks
tonight so tonight I think we're in for
a real feast and let me briefly
introduce to you our dinner first Doug
Saunders is the international affairs
columnist for The Globe and Mail an
award-winning journalist he has written
extensively on and from the Middle East
Russia India and Europe he's the author
of two highly regarded books arrival
city the final migration and our next
world daron acemoglu is the key Liam
professor of economics at MIT he has
received and deservedly received a truly
impressive number of awards for his
contributions to the science of
economics that I won't list all of them
but I will list some of them he's
received in 1989 the adam smith prize
the Woodrow Wilson foundation award the
john van noi minh award the john bates
clark medal for the most promising
economist under 40 in the United States
several honorary degrees the inaugural
gala Sarah prize and the numerous Prize
in Economics and I could go on most
importantly see if Darren is also a CFR
senior fellow in the program and
institutions organizations and growth
a Blee led by elhanan helpman who's here
in the audience tonight with some of his
colleagues that program the iog program
brings together some of the most
illustrious minds in economics political
science political economy anthropology
to examine the roles of institutions in
economic growth when I asked Ellen on
and the members of the advisory board
his advisory board why they come to iog
meetings the last time they met here in
Toronto and their next meeting starts
tomorrow here in Toronto the answer I
got was are you kidding the iog program
meetings are the best economics meetings
on earth and so in all for all of these
reasons it's a pleasure for me to
recognize Ellen and his colleagues
including their own here this evening
ladies and gentlemen please join you
please join me in welcoming their own
estimate
thank you very much Alan it's a great
pleasure to be here and I would like to
thank see far which has provided a
wonderful intellectual home for me and
for many of my colleagues and I would
like to thank scotiabank for supporting
CFR and supporting this event as Alan
mentioned I'm going to talk about the
main themes of my joint work with my
longtime collaborator James Robinson why
nations fail so the question that we try
to write on is is is one of the most
important questions in social science
why some nations are so much more
prosperous than others actually this was
the question that motivated Adam Smith
in writing the wealth of nations sort of
that was a unparalleled work in its
creativity and its impact it's shaped
the modern discipline of economics but
actually the puzzle that Adam Smith and
others sort of try to ponder at the time
has only deepened when Adam Smith was
writing probably the gap between the
poorest and the richest nation was on
the order of four or fivefold today it's
over forty fold so with such a jarring
gap between rich and poor nations it's
no surprise that theories abound if you
look at the pages of newspapers academic
or other articles you'll see a lot of
ideas about why some nations are
successful some argue that it's
geography it's a it's a it's a line of
argument that goes back many centuries
among others to the great French
philosopher montesquieu so it could be
that some nations have a climate that's
not conducive to growth or as
Montesquiou thought it's not that's not
conducive to hard work or it could be
that some eight nations don't have
access to another navigable rivers or
their soil quality is not good for
agriculture and lots of other Geographic
factors could be counted some others
suggest cultural factors are important
perhaps some religious belief systems
are not conducive to economic growth or
there are some Nash
cultures or other cultural attributes
that are essentially dysfunctional and
don't encourage hard work or
innovativeness yet another view which is
very popular among economists is that
economic success is about enlightened
leadership so the argument goes you know
it is societies that have adopted the
right policies that prosper and it's
those societies that have enlightened
leader or more often the right advisers
to those leaders hence the economists
who make those choices and and and
enhance prosperity and poverty emerges
so our argument in the book is that none
of these various viewpoints really
grapple get to the grapple wit or get to
the most important factors in fact the
sources of prosperity and poverty are
relatively simple in our argument
societies prosper when their
institutions provide the right
incentives and the right opportunities
to these people and it is a failure of
all nations regardless of geography or
cultural attitudes that they have not
provided incentives they have not
provided opportunities to that
population that has condemned them
authority to develop this argument we
talk of two polar cases of institutions
at one and what we talk of inclusive
economic institutions those are such
things as secured property rights or an
environment in which people can write
contract and unbiased judicial system
but also equally important a level
playing field provided by the government
and public services and other features
of the regulatory environment of a
society that ensures that the vast
majority of the citizens of a nation
have the incentives and the
opportunities to take part in economic
activities invest choose their
occupations and if they have the talent
and inclination become innovators and
entrepreneurs of the nation but the
problem is most societies throughout
history and even today are not ruled by
inclusive institutions but by extractive
economic institutions as the name
suggests extractive economic
institutions are those that have been
designed to extract resources from the
majority of society for the benefit of a
few and those few we refer in the book
as the elite the politically powerful
extractive economic institutions do the
opposite of inclusive institutions they
don't provide secure property rights
they don't provide an environment in
which you can write contracts and
relationship form relationships that you
can trust and most importantly they
create a tilted playing field
advantaging those who are politically
powerful extractive institutions look
after the interests of that elite rather
than bring prosperity to the society at
large but neither extractive
institutions nor inclusive institutions
exist in a vacuum they need to be
supported by a sort of political
institutions made from the same cloth
they need to be supported by political
institutions that cohere with the
structure of these economic institutions
in the case of extractive pilot economic
institutions we call those extractive
political institutions which are those
that concentrate political power in the
hands of that same elite and put no
constraints or few constraint on the
exercise of that power and it makes
sense if you have a system based on
slavery or forced labor the most extreme
form of a tilted playing field
extracting from some part of the society
for the benefit of the rest how could
that such a system be maintained if it
weren't also accompanied by a monopoly
of political power military power
judicial power in society by the same
elite benefiting from courts labor or
slavery in the same way inclusive
economic institutions need to be
supported by inclusive political
institutions which create a more equal
distribution of political power in
society to illustrate how institutions
work and why I have argued that it's not
cultural Geographic or enlightened
leadership views that are most important
for understanding the contours of
economic and political development
throughout the centuries and even today
I think there is no better way of doing
it than providing an example and there
is no better way to turn on there's no
better place to turn then the Americas
which is a place where the extremes
institutions of inclusive and extractive
variety and their history can be very
easily see and we can turn first to the
colonization of South America one of the
early colonization expeditions in 1516
was to the southern shore seaboard of
what is today Argentina which started
the colonization of Argentina in areas
around conquistador Juan Diaz the soleus
with three ships landed there in fifteen
sixteen and started this process of
colonization the soleus had exactly the
same colonization strategy that would
later be perfected by Cortez and Pizarro
with his three ships he had soldiers and
goldsmiths because he was interested in
acquiring valuable metals gold and
silver and using coercion in doing so
and using coercion in putting people the
the the native population of the area to
work so that they would pay tribute and
they would provide food for the Spanish
conquistadors but the Spaniards were met
by a rude awakening instead of finding
plentiful gold or silver they could they
didn't find any and instead of finding
big cities and large populations they
were confronted by essentially two bands
of Indians the chair was and the
carrandi which were very sparsely
settled very mobile hunter-gatherers
without any hierarchy the Spaniards
tried to capture them which wasn't easy
because they couldn't catch them when
they were quote they fought back and a
band of chair was duly killed Juan Diaz
de Sola sick few years after his landing
and when they were captured they would
refuse to work because they weren't used
to hierarchy and they weren't used to
working an agricultural production so
Spaniards were ready to get getting
ready to throw in the towel because they
were starving because they were totally
unprepared to put to produce food for
themselves and it was another one of the
conquistador one the iola's that saved
up that sailed up the Parana River to
what is today Asuncion Paraguay
and there he found another band of
Indians the Guarani the Quran er not the
Incas or the Aztecs they weren't you
know spectacular civilizations with huge
cities but they were still quite
different from the chair was and the
Quran d they were already sedentary they
were more densely settled then they had
their own hierarchy with princes and
princesses and Anna structure in which
many people work for the maintain Minh
of a high standard of living of those
princes and princesses so the Spaniards
militarily overpowered them declared
themselves the elite they married some
of the princesses so that they became
organically the elite of the society and
they militarily started dominating the
rest of society in particular taking
over and adapting the economic
institutions that the Quran ahead
therein lies the origins of institutions
such as the encomienda the land grants
with the together with the people on it
which was essentially a forced labor
system or the report miento which would
later be developed and perfected or
Damita system which was another forced
labor system and all of this of course
was supported as I was hinting in my
earlier discussion by a coercive
political structure that enabled those
Spanish Elise which were few in numbers
to actually militarily and politically
dominate society what about North
America well the North American
Colonization started somewhat later and
the most important part of it the
English colonization and a very early
example of it was the colonization of
Jamestown in 1607 this was led by the
Virginia Company which was a
profit-maximizing corporation chartered
in London and the Virginia company's
objective was to make profits from
colonization just like the Spaniards
were all those Spaniards were more
interested in making profits for their
crown because of the way that their
economy was organized but there was as
we'll see there's there's a lot of
parallel between what the Virginia
Company wanted and how it planned of
going about it as what the conquistadors
were doing in South America virginia
company sent in three ships and the
three ships surprise surprise were also
filled with soldiers and goldsmiths
because they thought well the spaniards
were successful with this strategy this
is we are
exactly the same thing we'll try the
same thing but they also had more or
less the same sort of events unfold as
the solises men they landed in virginia
jamestown and looked around and they
couldn't find any big cities or anything
like that they were confronted by a band
of sparsely settled mobile
hunter-gatherers and those indians were
again not cooperative in providing food
with them they would fight with them
they wouldn't cooperate and and the
English also went through exactly the
same phases they went through their own
starving time and it was again by a
series of coincidences perhaps due to
the ingenuity of John Smith that they
actually survived but ingenuity or not
John Smith or not they couldn't save up
some River and find a more densely
settled population that they could
overpower because there were none this
was the open frontier the mythical or
the real open frontier of North America
so the Virginia Company was at a bind
their plan wouldn't work so they
scratched their head and they came up
with a second plan they said if we
cannot create the society we want in the
new world by overpowering and enslaving
the people of the continent we can bring
our own lower strata who would do the
work and the captains and the elite of
the Virginia Company can still live off
the labor of others so they brought in a
bunch of an indentured servants just to
give you an idea of what the life of
these indentured servants the settlers
so called settlers was supposed to be
let me read from a passage from the laws
that the governor Sir Thomas Dale and
his deputy Sir Thomas gates actually
passed at this point no man or woman
shall run away from the colony to the
Indians upon pain of that anybody who
robs a garden public or private or a
vineyard or who steals ears of corn
shall be punished with death no member
of the colony will sell or give any
commodity of this country to a captain
Mariner master or sailor to transport
out of the colony or for his own private
use upon pain of death now two things
should strike you about this passage one
of that this was no happy shiny colony
everything that you could do was
punishable by death but actually there
was a method to this madness they were
actually worried about something very
specific they were worried about this
laborer that they
growth actually doing other things than
laboring for the benefit of the elite
they were worried about them running
away or trading on their own account for
their own profit but no matter whatever
threats they issued whatever draconian
punishments they'd meted out the open
frontier was two attractive people and
the working conditions were too awful
people ran away people started trading
on the side and at that point the
Virginia Company decided their second
strategy didn't work either so at that
point they had an even more radical
rethink and they said okay none of these
strategies are going to work we came up
with a third strategy but it was a total
about-face the third strategy which was
to introduce a head right system which
gave 50 acres of land to each settler to
be accompanied with another 50 acres if
they required it was the first time that
in the New World private property in
land was introduced they tell people now
you can grow whatever crops you want you
can sell them in whatever you are ways
you want you can just make money and
live within this colony we can no longer
realize our plan of creating the same
sort of colony that the Spaniards did
there was only one catch it was Sir
Thomas gates and Sir Thomas Dale just a
year ago threatening you with death even
if you sold an ear of corn and now they
tell you well you can have your private
property right you can do whatever you
want well you would be quite
understandable if you didn't trust them
so one year later in 1619 they did
another major thing they introduced the
General Assembly where the settlers
themselves would whole political power
so in the same way as I was hinting that
inclusive economic institutions cannot
exist in a vacuum here to inclusive
economic institutions needed to be
supported by inclusive political
institutions and therein lies the
origins of the sort of institutional
path that the north of the country took
so this episode is just one of many but
i think it's illustrative of several
things they saw in illustrator of how
economic and political institutions need
to complement each other but also it
shows the history of these institutions
how they came how they came about it
highlights that these inclusive
institutions weren't given because there
was some
myton leadership or some farsighted
behavior on the side of the elites it
came out often out of conflict out of
necessity out of some sort of struggle
but also this episode highlights why I
was somewhat categorical at the
beginning in saying Geographic cultural
or enlightened leadership explanations
don't have much to do with the origins
of these big differences in prosperity
and poverty let's go through them
geography well geography had nothing to
do with it it wasn't that soil quality
or productivity of land was better in
Jamestown than in other parts actually
the among the places that the the
soulless and his men colonized was when
Osiris and the pumpers around it which
are you know strikingly plentiful in
fact if you look at where the population
centers were at the time the Europeans
arrived it was in places such as the
Mexico Valley or the what is today / or
Bolivia and these places had these large
populations because they were the more
prosperous places they were the places
that had agriculture that could feed
huge cities so the fact that these
places are poor today has got nothing to
do with their agriculture blood being
productive in fact what we're seeing
today is a reversal is a reversal in
which places were more prosperous and
which places became more prosperous
after the Europeans arrived and hear
what was important is that where the
place where the population centers were
were much more attractive target for the
European colonial is setting up
extractive institutions as the contrast
of the chair was and the Quran d versus
the Guarani illustrates does it have
anything to do with culture after all
Spaniards paraded pray to God
differently they had their own different
cultures that that sharply diverse from
the English be that as it may the
cultural differences don't seem to have
played any role even though the
Spaniards were Catholic and the render
and English not they had exactly the
same strategy they went about it in
exactly the same way they failed in
exactly the same way but the Spaniards
could recover from it because they had
opportunities to actually realize their
colonization dreams the English did not
it was the conditions on the ground not
their cultural attitudes not their ways
of going about it which we remark
similar does it have anything to do with
enlightened leadership again the answer
is no in fact the opposite people like
Cortez and Pizarro and the Iola sent the
Toledo realized their dreams it was Sir
Thomas gates and Sir Thomas Dale who
failed they were given there were sent
there with a mission and they were as
failure in that mission it was just that
their mission was to set up an
extractive colony so it was good for the
future of the North American societies
that they failed in this mission so it
wasn't enlightened leadership but it was
the conditions that they encountered on
the ground of course this is just a
historical example but what we try to do
in the book is to try to give a sense
that many parts of the history of
economic and political development
really fit into this framework that I
have very quickly summarized here in
most cases that we have studied
prosperity or poverty don't have
Geographic or cultural or enlightened
leadership roots but they are really
related to incentives and those
incentives are shaped by institutions
and we really have to understand where
these institutions come from and how
they function what I have not explained
and Doug and I will probably talk a
little bit more about is how
institutions really change over time and
why they persist so after all the
encomienda system their apartment Oh
system the meter system and although the
extractive colonial regimes that were
set up in in South America have all
disappeared United States today has very
different institutions then it did under
during the Jamestown Colony but what we
need to understand is that even if
specific institutions sometimes go there
they create a path dependent process of
change we cannot understand how Mexico
is today without understanding how
Mexico was in the 19th century and you
cannot understand how Mexico was in the
19th century if you don't look at it
conquistador routes but history is not
destiny either societies do change they
break vicious circles they reform their
institution
sometimes radically sometimes in steps
so another big pillar of the theory has
to be about how successful change
happens how inclusive institutions
sometimes come out of the ashes of
extractive institutions and under what
circumstances those inclusive
institutions consolidate and under what
circumstances they reverse course and go
back to extractive institutions again
that's something that we try to sort of
talk in the book but in this short
introductory speech I'm not giving you a
much over the idea another theme which I
think we'll talk a little bit about is
that there isn't any sort of physical
law that says growth cannot happen under
one society versus another in fact all
societies can benefit from economic
growth it is just that our thesis argues
it is inclusive societies inclusive
economic and political institutions that
create the preconditions for sustainable
growth sometimes extractive societies
also attempt growth and some of the
successful growth episodes in history
are the outcomes of this extractive
growth process and part of the book is
dedicated to explaining what makes grow
extractive growth feasible but the most
important element here that I would like
to end with is that extractive growth
differently from inclusive growth is not
durable it has its the seeds of its own
decision in itself and the reason for
that is that extractive societies are
generally afraid of change because they
say survived by maintaining state by
maintaining the stability of an existing
power relation existing institutional
structure and growth which is
accompanied often with creative
destruction with the general chaos chaos
that innovation and new technologies
bring often create challenges deep
challenges for extractive society so
extractive societies only grow when they
can in a limited way control these
processes more more often they can grow
by just playing to the comparative
advantage or to by benefiting from
existing ideas in society so inclusive
societies are the ones that really
create the condition
for long run sustained economic growth I
think I will stop here and we'll
continue the conversation with Doc
Saunders who is going to now join me on
the podium thank you
one two three there we go can you hear
me now
I'll just shout really loudly how's that
this this book is this okay I think this
book marks a fairly influential and
important moment in that what Dharun has
done essentially is to revive the ID
haha there we go sorry institutions as
this central determinants of the the
fate and success of Nations the idea
that the institutions have a life of
their own and they continue on
regardless of the economic or social or
political circumstances around them that
they have a life of their own regardless
of the culture or religion or ideology
or individual personality or social
relations of production if you will of
the people who happen to be running them
you can have you can you can have
societies that that go from being a very
very liberal to being very Marxist that
go from being very from one religion to
another that go from being the colonized
to being the post-colonial that somehow
managed to have the same economic and
political outcomes because these
institutions stay in place and I think
that was an idea that a lot of us first
learned by reading max vapor and so on
and in a way this is this is bringing
back babers ideas of the of you know the
the what he called the routine ization
of authority and then so on the the idea
that institutions are central rather
than politics and so on this is
something that has not been present
enough I think in a lot of the arguments
about the fate of Nations the second
reason why I think is a very important
book is that it's provoked
debate about a set of assumptions that
we've had about the success and failure
of Nations and I think more importantly
the transformation of Nations from
failure to success that have focused on
other areas and this debate has often
been quite heated i mean darren has
managed to provoke probably the two
biggest figures in the world of of
transforming nations to take him on
Jeffrey Sachs and Bill Gates both of
whom have launched broadsides and doron
and his co-author to their credit have
fired back with great intensity
providing the kind of online rhetorical
fireworks that people like me
particularly enjoy and i would say that
while the rhetorical heat and
intellectual level of these debates has
been quite intense in a certain respect
the stakes have been profoundly small
because really underlying these debates
about this thesis is not such a profound
question as whether institutions are
irrelevant or not it's more a debate
between the word the and the word ah the
question of whether institutions are the
determinants of the success or failure
of Nations or whether institutions are a
determinant of the success or failure of
Nations and I think the the debate with
Jeffrey Sachs for all of its passionate
intensity really boils down to that
question I don't think anybody including
your fiercest critics would disagree
that institutions are crucial and very
important to these things that you've
done a great service by reintroducing
them to the center of the debate it is
merely a question of whether various
other things in which some of these
people have a lot invested or are in
their minds equally are more important
now let me ask a couple questions and
then we'll briefly because I'd like to
I'd like to give the audience a chance
to to
Grilli immerseus Lee and I'd like to
focus on on one area of the book that I
find sort of the hinge of this probably
because I tend to always find myself
running into places where revolutions
and crises are going on which is the
question you devote a very persuading
very persuasive job explaining how
extractive institutions have a
self-perpetuating almost homeostatic
nature to them in the sense that no
matter what happens they tend to stay in
place and once you get yourself to
having inclusive institutions they also
tend to be self-sustaining and so on the
question is the space in between those
two places as you point out more often
than not attempts to have a revolution
failed to transform institutions we've
seen this pretty vividly in Egypt
recently where a group of very very
different people took over the state and
managed to produce exactly the same
outcomes as the other people who are
there before in your book you have some
examples of places that have actually
transformed but Botswana the u.s. South
Post 1960 and China in a very highly
qualified way and and I let me ask you
though you can point to some other
countries that have managed to transform
themselves to being both economically
and politically messes to being
successful places i would say pick some
out of my hat I had I'd say South Korea
Poland Turkey and Brazil which if
somehow managed to become politically
and economically in the winning category
well many of their neighbors have not
and so on what has caused these places
to transform the nature of their
institutions
in this way such a diverse range of
places all during the last 20 years or
so is there is there a single thing I
believe you use the phrase at one point
that with Botswana that they were able
to seize a critical juncture is there a
magic moment that countries need to grab
in order to change the institutions
thanks Doug I think that's the crux of
the matter I think there isn't a uniform
answer to the questions of how countries
transform themselves into more inclusive
institutions exactly like you've said
and we call this in the book vicious and
virtuous circles inclusive institutions
tend to persist because they have they
create a more the streak will
distribution of political power and an
economic structure that sort of is also
more participatory and that makes
overtaking of these institutions and
political power more difficult and but
the flip side of that is that extractive
institutions creative in a more
formidable persistence mechanism the
vicious circle which makes it very
difficult to break things even if you
have revolutions those revolutions
happen in the context of unshared
unbridled political power and the new
power holders have an incentive and have
the possibility to behave in exactly the
same way and things happen in a very
conflict-ridden way which creates
infighting and civil wars which further
sort of strengthens the room for
extractive economic political and
economic institutions to emerge and
persist but when we see you know history
does have many examples of of societies
that have broken out of extractive
institutions in the book we discuss
exactly like you've said Doug Botswana
us South China but also Japan during the
Meiji Restoration the the French
Revolution of course the transformation
of the German
germany you know German princelings
princely states and and and and in
cities and and also quite importantly
the British case or the English case
which starts again from a quasi
absolutist monarchy and works through a
more inclusive set of institutions over
time and when you look at all of these
things I think one common element is the
presence of conflict so the none of this
happens in a straightforward manner it
takes place with some groups solving
their collective action problem and
articulating demands and if these
demands are sufficiently broad based and
take place in a way that can supplant
existing extractive institutions that
opens the way but for every successful
case of such a transformation there are
failures too and there are sort of two
major paths that one perhaps can see
within this uncertain conflict-ridden
world one is the sort of the English
path where though still conflict driven
these institutional reforms took place
rather gradually first you had the
Parliament becoming more powerful
restricting the pejoratives of the
purgatives of this of the monarch the
absolutism being transformed into
constitutional monarchy better judicial
institutions emerging and only over time
the bureaucracy becomes more
meritocratic the private property
becomes even further strengthened and
then the British democracy gets going so
that's a very very gradual progress on
the other hand you have cases like the
French Revolution or what we are sort of
now seeing in Egypt which the existing
regime is sufficiently strong and has
staying power that it actually resist
attempts to change it and this whole
boiled the whole thing boils to a
revolution and those revolutionary
changes unfortunately are much more
unpredictable and even when they work to
a better outcome like in the French
Revolution they do so as a process after
a process of quite a lot of chaos and
sometimes very slowly so when you look
at
uh sort of some of the examples that you
have mentioned I think the ones that
have been somewhat successful have so
far avoided the revolutionary outcome
again Egypt is a question mark where
it's going to go south korea for example
you know the economic institutions
started becoming more inclusive after
the separation of south and north but
the but it was only 20 years after that
that the political institutions became
more democratic because people's workers
and students went on the streets and
demonstrated the military didn't want to
didn't want to relinquish power but they
were they failed in their repression and
the whole thing sort of try sort of
started unraveling Brazil likewise you
know the the changes in Brazil came out
of fairly major unrest sand strikes
against the military regime that sort of
were the beginning of democracy in
Brazil and and democracy in this case
was quite important in also transforming
the economic institutions of Brazil and
and and and and and public services and
redistribution as well as economic
activities have changed quite a lot
after the military regime in Brazil but
you know then you also have some
idiosyncratic factors so for instance if
you're talking about Poland or the rest
of Eastern Europe to Czech Republic
Slovakia Hungary I think in those cases
the transition to a market economy and
to inclusive political institutions has
been unusually smooth partly perhaps
because of the impact of the European
Union which is that it acted as a carrot
and a stick on these nations so so I
think the there isn't a single uniform
path that each of these countries are
going to take and and as a result it's
also and every every one of these paths
is also to some degree quite difficult
and full of challenges and I think that
comes back to the Egyptian question that
you know in Egypt you have one tyrant
being overthrown but then we now have a
situation in which political power is
still centralized in the hands of the
only party that was
in terms of his organizations to
actually compete in an election and and
it also feels that it has it it has a
mission that's different from what the
rest of the society work once so so the
conflict is actually getting quite
strong in the Egyptian society and again
only time will show whether this despite
this car of conflict and the instability
that will go on ultimately will take the
path of something like the French
Revolution where Egyptian institutions
will get stronger over time or whether
it will be like the Bolshevik Revolution
where the new masters make the old ones
appear tame when you when we hear the
words extractive institutions we tend to
think of resource economies and so on
and that's that's in a way it's an
expansion I think of the idea of the
rent GA economy and so on is as being
something that holds people back and so
on one question that arises is is it
easier for countries to make this
transition from from being extractive to
being inclusive if they're not wealthy a
lot of the countries that have changed
have changed and then become wealthy
South Korea comes to mind and and and
and so on and the lot of the
post-communist transition countries that
have on the other hand in places where
there is wealth already and the elites
are caught up in a set of institutions
that are making them extremely wealthy
do you think that the prospects are much
lower for a change in a place like that
I mean Russia perhaps being an example
of a place where before there could be
any transformation various people were
able to seize the sources of resource
wealth and maintain them and so on where
you could argue that in places like
Poland that didn't have resource wealth
the stakes were lower so institutions
could form differently could a place
like Saudi Arabia or for that matter
let's say Libya in the next few years
where the basis of these institutions
is the extraordinary enrichment of their
of their participants have any chance of
becoming inclusive I think that's a
great question and the answer I would
like to give I think as part of the
answer I would first like to pose a
different question which is you know why
was it that for instance when people
organized in 1830 in the in the late
1820s and 1830s in England and went on
the streets and demanded political
rights when England was ruled by
essentially an oligarchy less than 2% of
the population who had representation in
Parliament why didn't the the elites
decide to send in the troops and kill
everybody and start a regime of
repression in contrast when similar
demands were articulated in Russia or
austria-hungary you know there was
repression and I think the ouster partly
is related to economic structure I think
in Britain by the time was sufficiently
urbanized sufficiently industrialized
the economy dependent sufficiently on
commerce that repression became both
harder to maintain would have been and
also less attractive for people so there
as a result in 1832 they passed the
first Reform Act and said fine we'll
share power and then that sort of
continued in the process of
democratization of Britain so economic
structure matters a lot and if your
wealth is in land or is in resources
it's much easier to repress and it's
actually much more attractive to the
press if you're in capital owner if
you're a factory owner if you're a new
style entrepreneur where innovation and
ideas are your currency you're not that
afraid of being expropriated because
nobody can take over facebook and run it
in the same way as Zukerman is doing so
but if you are sitting on top of oil
fields then anybody can take that over
so if you're sitting over some cotton
fields anybody can take that over and
you know perhaps they won't be able to
do it as as effectively at first but
land is also much easier
take over so all of these factors mean
that there are certain economic
structures that are going to be more
conducive to repression and some others
that are going to open the way to to it
to a more smoother transition to
inclusive institutions but crucially
those are not characteristics of
countries in general so countries all
start in land and they they they
progress into into into into other
commercial service and industrial
activities so as a result it is to
something related to the stage of
development and that might also be
related to our fort awhile in South
Korea you know the the ability of the
are the military to control political
power started getting looser as the
economy started developing but on the
other hand as the Russia Saudi Arabia
and countless other examples show there
there are other cases in which countries
grow and as they grow that increases the
legitimacy of the regime it increases
the willingness of the regime to
actually hang on to power and there is
no transition to inclusive institutions
so in particular one of the things that
are we talked about in the book somewhat
is sort of contrasting our perspective
to the famous sociological political
theory of modernization theory which was
articulated by Martin Seymour lipsett
which says you know democracy and and
other aspects of institutions presumably
kind of naturally and automatically
become better and improve once the
society becomes more prosperous and we
show we've we've shown with sort of more
statistical econometrics working in
research and then we sort of argue using
some historical and other evidence in
the book that actually the evidence
doesn't support this there isn't a sort
of an automatic or even easy process of
growth immediately leading to inclusive
institutions there is oh it's always a
struggle it's always an uncertain
process for this inclusive institutions
to emerge and that's an assorted keith
is I think what I'd find it like to ask
you about is precisely that question you
are throwing into question the idea that
if you can get some economic growth
happening that the society and the
politics will will transform themselves
automatically there is that
modernization theory there's a whole
bunch of ideas which essentially say
there's a is a teleological impulse to
the improvement of Nations that means
that inevitably once you have the stuff
down there running properly that life
will change in this way because it
happened with the number of nations uh
during the let's say the
post-enlightenment centuries and then
with places like China and so on it
didn't and this leads me a question of
to what extent can we come in from
outside and and and make things change
and I mean you're most outspoken critics
have been any most famous critics have
been the probably the two people who run
the biggest institutions devoted to the
attempt by North Americans to transform
transform nations and Bill Gates is
critique of you was sort of based on a
defense of modernization theory on the
idea that simply by creating some growth
and changing the minds of the leadership
I mean his his sort of money quote was
saying that China's transition actually
occurred because quote the leadership
embraced capitalistic economics
including private property markets and
investments in infrastructure and
education that this is change in
thinking caused the change Jeffrey Sachs
he comes at you from a number of angles
related to his work in his
organization's work in Africa and so on
but essentially is arguing that by
changing various physical and living
circumstances what broadly get called
the geographical circumstances that you
can promote that type of transformation
in states these are people who are part
of the aid the aid universe and so on
who are essentially defending the basis
of their enormous aid investments
against some of the conclusions of your
book is is there any point in aid is
there something we should be directed at
uh do people like George Soros who do
tend to push on the institutional level
have some hope or some success in
helping transform from extractive to
inclusive I think the first you know I
don't want to claim that outside
interventions never work I think the
difficulty is that outside interventions
can only work if they have the basis in
the inside society you cannot impose
institutions from the outside and the
Eastern European European Union sort of
case that i mentioned worked because
there was a demand for more greater
democratization for a market economy for
sidelining the communist regime and the
sort of the carrot stick policy of the
european union played into that the
Marshall Plan likewise but that's
difficult and the track record of
transforming societies from poor to
prosperous through outside interventions
is woefully poor this is not to say that
foreign aid is useless in the book we
are very clear in saying that you know
most of foreign aid izzy is wasted and
it is sort of naive to expect that
foreign aid is going to transform you
know the Democratic Republic of Congo
into the next Switzerland but you know
four and eight and often goes to the
most needy areas and even if one dollar
out of ten reaches there that's great
but I think it is important to be
realistic in what foreign aid can
achieve and not sort of this ingenious
in pretending that it can achieve things
that it cannot so for instance here is a
great success of foreign aid or foreign
intervention of sorts it's the wh 0 and
international organizations in the 40s
50s and the 60s bringing all sorts of
new drugs to the developing countries
antibiotics
vaccines against smallpox DDT against
mosquitoes and malaria and a whole host
of other drugs that broke the back of
pneumonia all sorts of bacterial
diseases you had an unparalleled
transformation in the rest of the world
life expectancy increased from 30 to 60
in places such as parts of India or
Guatemala or Ecuador but if you believe
sort of the sort of the view that all we
need to do is sort of poor a this should
have also been transformative in terms
of the economies of these places no this
was a great thing it was probably one of
the highest social values in terms of
intervention but it did not transform
these places economically none of these
places were much richer after the
transformation and if you look at their
trend growth rates you don't see any
changes and the part of the reason is
that because economic development is
much more than just what we're going to
bring drugs it's much more than we're
going to bring money of course if you
bring the right drugs people live longer
which is even more important than
economic development it's a good in
itself so foreign aid is something we
should be commended this particular
interracial something that we commended
but it also highlights again that
economic development is not just about
one or two or three interventions from
the outside it's really about a
fundamental institutional transformation
that is both in the economics politics
and more generally social fabric of
these societies that's necessary and no
amount of foreign technical solutions to
that problem is going to achieve that
unless the dynamics inside the countries
also becomes takes a turn towards the
more inclusive one well thank you I
think at this point let's let the
audience ask because I suspect the
collective knowledge and in most cases
the individual knowledge of of people
here in front of me exceeds my own and
we seem to have a couple microphones
here and here is there one in the middle
as well now this is this microphone
there one on the opposite side and I
will I'm going to adopt a prac
that I learned doing things like this
during my last eight or nine years
living in England which is to take
questions in groups of three which tends
to produce a more richer dialogue the
other thing I learned doing events like
this over the last eight or nine years
in England is to have alcohol instead of
water on the table here but too late for
that well why don't we begin sir yes I
greatly appreciate you sharing your
insightful views and your deep knowledge
of many societies I would point out
though that in your characterization of
the UK is on its path to becoming an
inclusive society or with inclusive
institutions at the same time UK was a
colonial power exercising rather
unlimited sway with its armies or in
sort of extractive institutions imposing
them on its colonial Nations so how do
you reconcile those two aspects and
second from this side here the your
thesis is optimistic by Nature it seems
to be saying that you know the old
adages of might is right or geography is
destiny as not as as much of a truism as
as we have historically assumed let me
if I may pose the question in terms of a
case like most Canadians my heritage is
from somewhere else my heritage is
Armenian and Armenia is a population of
three million is landlocked and has four
neighbors two of whom are hostile to it
and yet historically it has institutions
and today in terms of nation building
and capacity building it appears to be
facing difficulties and not
accomplishing nation building and
capacity building and that it seems to
be locked into the old adage of
geography is destiny I'd be interested
in your thoughts since there's two
microphones why don't we
why don't we address these two it ago
what do you think okay yeah that's a
little bit ago so 22 excellent questions
let me start in the order i receive
absolutely and I think we sort of tried
to emphasize this in the book but I
didn't talk about it in this brief
presentation the history of economic
development political development for
much of the country's the history of
colonization and that colonization was
done by you know as I hinted at by
britain by Spain Portugal France the
Dutch and none of these had very
different objectives they all tried to
extract resources exploit the
populations that they found but that's
sort of to me underscores the sort of
ideas that I was talking about there
wasn't anything culturally value was
different in Britain than Spain it was
just that Britain had inclusive
institutions and inclusive institutions
are good for those who are included so i
define inclusive institutions in britain
as those that includes the people in
Britain who had political voice and and
lived on the British Isles but then once
those institutions start looking after
the interest of their own people that
depending on the historical context
might also involve doing very bad things
to the rest of the world and I think the
same applies and many other instances so
I think what are the things that we say
in the book is that there are no heroes
in this book unfortunately so you know
you're not going to expect anybody who
has the political power to use that
political power for against their own
strong interests and for the for the
good of the society you know unless they
are there are some specific ideological
or other reasons that override these
things so so for that very reason
British politicians did exactly what you
know benefited the Britain as a country
at the expense of the rest of society so
I think that sort of underscores exactly
the same same say the ideas that I was
sort of talking about and that's that's
the light under which we
of this custom here on Armenia actually
I happen to be of Armenian descent also
so I've followed Armenia to some degree
but not as closely as the gentleman who
asked the question but I would submit
that armenia's problems have little to
do with being landlocked Armenia is
going through exactly the same sort of
problems as all the other Russian
republics are and all of these other
Russian Republic's or former Soviet
republics or Russian Republic is the
wrong word all forms for Soviet
republics are in a vicious circle in
which the Communist elites and their
allies have taken over political power
in these countries with weak
institutions and and and i have created
a very sort of a different guise of an
extractive society in some cases the
outcome hasn't been totally disastrous
because there are natural resources that
have kept those countries afloat but if
you look at a jig is done kyrgyzstan
whose back is down which is you know a
nightmare of unbelievable proportions
they are no different than armenia and
armenia has suffered from extremely
corrupt and self-regarding sometimes
repressive leaders that have bled the
country dry you know the big problem
that armenia has now is everybody
fleeing the country now of course it
hasn't been helped by its geographic
position not because it's landlocked so
much but it's because it's next to
Azerbaijan where you know a civil war of
great destructiveness has been fought
and and its relationship to Turkey is
not very good so it's not able to trade
through fairly open trade routes that
would have been available to the country
landlocked or not but it's a job
geopolitical situation which is sort of
more of an extension of the ideas that I
have talked about to the international
dimension that's more important than
being landlocked per se I suppose
Switzerland's plan Lord yes and there is
nothing too bad yeah
here I understand that you're talking
about the differences between nations
but I'm curious about how your theory of
institutions would explain the growing
disparity of power prosperity and
poverty within nations the is the
religious cultural dynamic significant
within nations actually we talked about
that a little bit in the book you know
at the end of the day there isn't a sort
of a discontinuous way of sort of saying
this is between nations this is within
nations as Tip O'Neill in the United
States said all políticas law or
politics is local you know that's true
everywhere in the world a lot of the
political aspects that we're emphasizing
in the book are at the local level there
are local chiefs in Africa that are the
most important part of the government if
you want to understand African poverty
you have to understand the Chiefs as
much as the African leaders and you have
great inequity great inequalities in
terms of prosperity and poverty within
nations you know this was true of the of
the United States you know at the time
just before the Civil War us-south was
less than a half of the income per
capita as the north and why again I
think the the most plausible and the
most realistic answer is institutions
you know u.s. South was not innovative
it was not using the best technology was
not productive in the crops that it it
produced because it had a slavery
repressive system so the same sort of
factors explain a lot of the within
nation difficulty differences but of
course the nation often puts a framework
into it and again the u.s. South versus
North sort of illustrates it when the
u.s. south and the North diverts too
much and that divergence sort of
conflict started conflicting then the
federal national institutions sort of
interfere in bringing the two into line
so the nation is not totally irrelevant
but i think the ideas here are slightly
are broader than just applying
at a national or a federal level
religion and culture I find this a very
difficult question in the sense that of
course religion culture beliefs they do
matter they do matter greatly for a lot
of things I mean if you think of
institutions you know what are
institutions that at the end of the day
institutions are only worth something to
the extent that people understand that
and people obey them and they really
shape incentives if I declare a
constitution but nobody believes that
nobody thinks that it's going to be
enforced it doesn't mean anything so the
beliefs in general matter in that
context but I have taken a fairly strong
line in saying culture protested versus
Catholic Muslim versus Christian
Buddhist versus Jewish or whatever
they're not first order because when you
look at historical episodes we look at
the econometric in the statistical data
those things seem to be generally
second-order was max waiver right in
emphasizing protesting ethic perhaps
there was something that was associated
with the protest anism that was
particularly rebellious against
Authority which was important in
transforming European societies at the
time but look at one hundred years later
Catholic countries were as good in
industrialism industrializing and and
trading as the different ways of
Protestant countries so I think religion
of course matters culture of course
matters for certain things but these
things are also extremely plastic and
they change and I think the best way of
understanding their impact and their
dynamics is in conjunction with
institutions and the politics of it
which is what we've tried to do do I
would I embellish that a bit further
asking you do you think that do you
think that some institutional change
causes sometimes cultural change I'm
making the given a number of countries
that when they've transformed their
economies the culture has changed very
dramatically as almost overnight as a
result people talk about how you know
the Germans were the lazy slow-moving
inefficient people with bad roads the
Japanese until well into the 20th
century were the unemployable
uh filthy uh unproductive people the
Chinese were the confusion sort of
obeying orders and not taking
entrepreneurial even the Irish you look
at what I mean Ireland sort of had a
very quick institutional transformation
at a certain point I from being very
dependent Eisenhower Eisenhower said
when civil rights movement started that
you cannot change people's views with
guns and look at what happened in the
u.s. South of course you know there is
still racism in u.s. South is there is
everywhere else but you know three
decades after the Civil Rights and and
and all of the court cases and executive
orders today attitudes towards race are
fundamentally different in the u.s.
South as they were during the Jim Crow
so you know culture did change at that
level American culture changed
profoundly over the last sixty years
it's not they're not the same people
yeah and who knows anyway back to here
um hi similar to the last question going
back to the beginning of your lecture
you mentioned that it was institutions
that are the reason why some nations
fail and some succeed but largely
following on the works of jared diamond
isn't geography a huge part of this as
well if you think about it the reasons
why the aztecs the Incas damari the band
to the Papuans why they did not build
successful civilizations that went and
colonized europe other other than the
other way around was because they lacked
the resources the the type of
agricultural products large domestic a
little animals things like that and then
using that you're up the middle east
east asia we're able to use these
resources to build up the institutions
which they then use to succeed further
on what do you think about this my
question really relates to
sustainability i think in your initial
introduction you made reference to
inclusive institutions as being more
durable than extractive and i would not
disagree i agree completely with that my
concern is
that if without having had the benefit
read your book yet the examples you've
used tonight both of you have all been
very short-term examples 20 years 30
years 40 or 60 years in terms of the
u.s. in terms of historic views of
dynamic generations and institutions
over the years where you've got previous
things at last six seven eight hundred
years of dynasties we are still in a
very early stage of something you
mentioned that the British inclusion was
started in 1832 that's only that's less
than 200 years ago I mean come on we're
just waking up curry has only been 25
years my kids aren't even my grandkids
are almost at ease so you know you've
got no long-term view of your theory on
any of the examples we've given tonight
so my question to you really relates to
two things that bothered me a lot in
terms of the Western democracies in the
last 15 years the increasing spread of
income disparity which is getting you
know out of hand i think at north
america and and the UK lesser so in
europe certainly in netherlands and
scandinavia to a different degree much
different degree but that's causing a
real problem with respect to taking away
inclusiveness and creating an elite
group of people who control the
political as well as the institutional
realms of power within our institution
but more than that and what is not
talked about very much is if you look at
the reducing mobility social economic
mobility in the Americas in North
America in particular the the chances of
people today moving from one social
class to another in the US are way less
that it was in Britain during the 1830s
1840s and they're getting worse in that
regard so the social mobility of most of
the Western democracy safe Canada is
getting much more rigid much more
difficult which means that you're
getting a retention of privilege and
control into an increasingly small
number of people to talk through both
income disparity and the restriction on
social mobility are you not concerned
that your so-called durable level of
inclusiveness will not be
self-destructive itself if we don't find
a way
our institutions to address those two
problems okay so on geography I think
it's hard to say whether it is it was
feasible for the Incas ever come and
colonize the rest of the world but we do
know a lot of things first of all the
fact that the Incas in our in today's
Peru or Bolivia and the Aztecs in the
Mexico Valley were the richest
civilizations in the in the Americas
that had nothing to do with geography
there was nothing special about these
places that distinguishes them from the
Mississippi Valley or from the pompous
or from the prairies of the Midwest that
made them specifically the places where
population had to concentrate it was
where the political innovations and the
organizations were successful that these
civilizations concentrated we also know
that it wasn't because the Spaniards had
access to horses and to wheat that
enable them to go and colonize the rest
of the world so did the polish so that
the Hungarians so that the Chinese so
did the Ottomans so did the Moldovans so
that the French so that the Danish so
why was it the Spaniards why wasn't it
it was the Eastern Europeans that became
rich again the answer has nothing to do
with geography it has nothing to do with
which crops are available in one part of
Europe or one part of Eurasia versus
another it was again about social
organization political organization
economic organization and all the
incentives economic and political that
these created now with all of that
perspective do I think that if I want to
tell the story of the world it's so
important that the Incas had the llamas
instead of horses I think that second
order but you know reasonable people can
disagree on the Incas verse
the Aztecs as opposed to the Spaniards
but I don't think reasonable people can
disagree that there wasn't the sort of a
geographic reason there was a geographic
reason that made one part of Europe so
much more prosperous versus another part
of Europe so on the question of the that
the other day that that was asked from
this side I mean it's a very long
question with several parts and there
are several interesting issues there I
don't know how much details to go into
but let me sort of first say about the
first part of the question which is that
yes I agree with the the sort of the
subtext of the first part that you know
at the end we have a in the in the
context of human history we have a short
experiment it's certainly not 20 years
or 30 years we're talking about 200
years from the inception of things that
we can truly call inclusive economic and
political institutions taking root but
the Roman Empire has been around for you
know was around for 600 years the
Chinese Empire for longer so perhaps
relative to that is short but actually
I'm not sure whether the years are the
right metric for measuring time here if
you look at the amount of economic
political social change we have we are
experiencing something that's
unprecedented you know during the Roman
Empire the income per capita during that
six hundred years perhaps increased by
forty fifty percent from the poorest to
the Ricky to the to the from the
beginning to the to the end of the of
that era from the 1800s to today income
per capita in many parts of the richest
poorer world today has more than
increased by more than eight times so if
you look at by that metric we have
already achieved something that I think
is unprecedented in history but yes you
are right it's 200 years and 200 years
as a rather short time in human history
and moreover again we discussed this
quite a bit in the book there is no
necessity that inclusive institutions
will be forever they are subject to
challenge
what makes them somewhat virtue a part
of the virtuous circle as I tried to
hint during my short presentation is
that they do have some flexibility
because of the more equal distribution
of political power and there are other
features to actually withstand these
challenges and then with the book we
talk about some examples in which they
have been able to withstand these
challenges but on the other hand we also
talk about cases such as Venice we're
starting from relatively inclusive
institutions you've seen the extractive
political institutions set in these made
economic institutions more extractive
and the Venice change direction and
became much poorer and much less much
less able to take advantage of its
economic opportunities and you know the
up to the pessimistic read is that in
the United States we are witnessing the
same thing that just like in Venice
you're seeing a turn to the extractive
you know you have the higher income
inequality perhaps more worryingly you
have much greater in political
inequality in the United States you know
United States at some point was you was
known as the country in which the
average Joe had the political power and
today it's only if you're wealthy and
you are an expert or you're connected to
the lobbying complex that you have
political voice and perhaps that's the
beginning of the setting in of the
extractive institutions I think that is
a real concern again only time will show
but what we sort of dis to discuss James
and I not in the book but in other
contexts in other articles that we have
written is that you know United States
has also been very able to sort of live
through similar challenges during the
era of the Gilded Age in the robber
barons and during the challenges that
the Jim Crow and the segregation and all
of the sort of gamut of extractive
arrangements in the south post and us
institutions showed sufficient
flexibility to withstand these
challenges and so I think there is some
there is a possibility of being
optimistic if not complacent in this
context but I think these are obviously
important issues that that that that
shouldn't be belittled
I haven't read your book but I'm
guessing that the general story is still
the rise of the of Europe versus the
rest of the world that's just the
age-old question in history of sociology
and whatnot so the expedition you're
giving is the role of institutions but
is is another explanation basically the
role of the military role of war can we
see Europe is basically a continent
that's subsumed by war for hundreds of
years before most of the Wars of
Religion and whatnot this may to Europe
more effective at war making that other
parts of the world and they basically
exported this abroad I mean I've heard
of this exploration would you consider
about that thank you for coming out I
too have not read your book I plan to in
unbundling ex institutions you talk
about how there's more statistical
support for the power of institutions
which protect people from government
expropriation versus institutions which
protect people from private contracts
which are broken and there was just a
question about time frame and I'd like
to ask another in relation to that one
of the biggest growth stories that we
know of is written in the industrial
revolution and if I think of the last
major institutional change of the
government level it was 1688 before that
and I was wondering if it's true that
it's the the institutions and government
that changed the matter too much wyd the
long lag time until we see the
industrial revolution and specifically I
would wonder how would you address the
arguments of Joel mccure in the
enlightened economy of the importance of
civil society and rationalism in
promoting growth thank you so war is
obviously very important military power
all of those are very important and and
one of the many things that we had to
leave out of the book just both because
you know it's not a topic that we felt
comfortable writing extensively about
and also the book was already too long
is the International dimension that we
only treat cursorily so I think the
international dimension does deserve
much much more detailed study and and
and there are some very famous ideas and
social science for example Charles
Tilly's idea that you know war made
states made war but warm eight states
and those states were important for the
economic development political
development of Europe I think the
reality is complex however you know you
had for centuries you had very
successful war making empires from Jenga
scan to timber lane to the Ottoman
Empire that were very successful
militarily but did not translate that
into any sort of economic success but
but obviously the military power of
Britain and Spain England and Spain did
play a role in their ability to expand
and build a colonial empire and that did
feed back into their domestic economics
and Dekka domestic politics so so I
think it's not a sort of a uniform
simple sort of link from if you are
successful militarily you're going to
become economically successful or war is
going to bring economic progress you
know war has brought more often
destruction and and poverty throughout
the world but but but i think the sort
of international control of violence and
international use of military military
power i think are very important topics
to be studied in greater degree on all
unbundling institutions thanks for
bringing some of my academic research
yeah I mean that was a success was if
that was a surprise to us that you know
what we found were was that at least in
the sample that we were looking at
institutions that regulated the
relationship between
government and society between what i
would call elites and society were much
more important than contracting
institutions which determine how
efficiently you could write contracts or
or or how the course worked in private
business deals and that was a big
surprise to me and i think it sort of
reflects to some degree the fact that
the real challenge to the inclusivity in
many cases not always comes from the
politically powerful the elite being
able to tilt the playing field to its
favor and and i think that those are
exactly the dimensions in which British
is the English British institutions
changed quite significantly from 1688
onwards you know Glorious Revolution was
a very radical affair it really changed
the relationship between monarchy and
society it really changed what the
monarch could do it really solidify the
private property rights perhaps not the
Juara but effectively de facto there
were several very important court cases
which really pitted the aristocratic
powers and a very connected companies
such as the East India Company against
small merchants where the outcome would
have been very very different before
1688 as after and those were I think
quite transformative and those were the
roots of the changes that really
underpin the Industrial Revolution of
course the Industrial Revolution was not
going to be possible without the
Enlightenment and the scientific
revolution that surrounded it but i
think the Scientific Revolution was also
in Italy and was also in other parts of
Europe but they were the world the
places that did not have the inclusive
institutions and that's not where the
Industrial Revolution took place thank
you very much for coming here today I
have a two-part question both parts
having to do with metrics the first is
what is the standard by which we are
judging whether a state is a success or
a failure so we have some countries in
the Gulf region that have a very high
standard of living at least for the
citizens
but a very low in inclusiveness so are
those states successes or failures and
number two how inclusive do institutions
need to be in order for a state to be
considered successful is a state with
the most inclusive political and
economic institutions intrinsically
bound to be the most successful and if
so what does this mean for the the the
value of work an economy based on worker
led organizations so in your lost
comments you spoke a little bit about
internationalization and I just wanted
to direct your attention to that a bit
more squarely so in the last you know in
the post-war era we've seen the
globalization of a lot of institutions
we've seen the UN the ICC for example as
a judicial institution do you see a role
for global institutions either
independently or in interaction with
national institutions I mean you talked
about sort of foreign aid as a very
specific thing that we could deal with
globally but didn't really play into
this framework so I'm just wondering if
you could address that again let me the
tradition to take it this in this order
I think we it is a little bit of an
unfortunate thing in writing in this
forum that perhaps we may have created
the impression that you know societies
are either inclusive or extractive and
that's not what we meant to do we try to
say this once or twice in the book but
perhaps not clearly enough it said
continuum inclusive and extractive the
way that we've sort of described it are
the ideal types like the two extremes
but if you look at most societies there
somewhere in between United States 19th
century was a fairly inclusive society
with a very very big extractive part in
the south even throughout the 650s and
the four knees and
and 60s same thing so so so therefore no
country is fully extractive know if our
country is fully inclusive and it's all
shades of grey so i'm not sure that i
need to sort of really say that you know
there is a threshold about what you're
going to be inclusive but but but you
know of course in discussing special
cases you may put more emphasis on their
includes over and the extractive
elements in terms of what is the metric
for success so we have defined success
very much on economic terms and and and
successful are those countries that are
able to to generate prosperity and i
think even when you look at countries
which have great natural resource wealth
from diamonds to oil the general lessons
that we are talking about apply and
countries generally are not just rich
because they have oil sometimes they
have oil like nigeria and they make a
mess of it sometimes they have diamond
like sierra leone or angola and they
have civil wars on it sometimes they
have oil like norway and they become
very rich sometimes they have diamonds
like botswana and they are able to use
it and build a very smelly to critic an
effective state system and in a
democracy on top of it I think the
exceptions you can take here are you
know which you probably had in mind are
Qatar and to some degree United Arab
Emirates which are very very prosperous
despite having what you would definitely
call an extractive political system and
sort of a mixture oh and extractive and
inclusive economic institutions and I
think you know you can take them to be
extreme cases very small countries with
huge oil reserves or you can take them
as the exceptions or that that sort of
to the to the theory but for the four if
you look at other oil
producer countries like Saudi Arabia
Kuwait I think you see exactly the sort
of issues that we're talking about you
know Saudi Arabia also has huge oil
wealth but it's not a very very
prosperous country it's more prosperous
than some of its neighbors but it's very
extractive political and economic system
is really holding that country back so I
think generally the lessons the that
we're trying to sort of this still are
applicable even to countries that have a
very important natural resource wealth
and and I wouldn't I wouldn't want to
sort of exclude them but Qatar in
particular is obviously sort of an
exceptional case I am going to demagogue
this evening to a quicker close to use
Newt Gingrich's favorite verb by asking
their remaining four people at the
microphone to ask your questions all
four of them in quick succession in two
or three concise sentences and I will
entrust so Allison their own texture the
last question that I didn't get I will
ask sorry about that let's find out and
as drone to provide an omnibus answer
which encapsulates all four of them into
a almost orchestral summation if you can
pull that off so starting here this is
the marathon session mine will be very
short and in what way do you agree that
corruption in a society is inversely
proportional very often to its economic
success and how can structures be
effective and institutions be effective
when corruption is very large doesn't
that affect even though corruption is a
cultural activity it affects the result
of economic achievement in a country
thank you we're in your opinion which
nations today tend to have the people
that shape and run institutions that
tend to be more inclusive
three nations if you can pick me the top
three nations which tend to have the
most inclusive institutions hi I'd like
to suggest that geography may play a
role in in creating external pressures
for regimes to innovate in terms of
institutions and one exempt like having
mind is in Europe given that we have
England France Germany Spain all these
countries of roughly similar levels of
power they have to compete with each
other that need for competition creates
a need an incentive for the regime's to
innovate whereas for example in China
the utter dominance of power by the
Chinese creates less need for them to
innovate institutionally to compete with
with any anyone would you comment on
that thank you and those societies were
extractive institutions have become
particularly entrenched and in the
absence of critical junctures what are
some characteristics they can develop to
at least position themselves in the
future to make a transition to more
inclusive institutions Wow okay so very
briefly first of all let me go back to
the excellent question on the
international institutions I'll be
extremely quick brief I think
international institutions are very
important because power political power
military power is increasingly
international I think a great example
which has both the strengths and the
failings of international institutions
is the European Union which sort of was
quite instrumental in the bringing of
peace to Europe but it's also created a
lot of tensions in terms of the economic
front so i think that sort of
illustrates some of the pros and cons of
internet and solve the challenges of
international institutions on corruption
I think corruption is very important but
it's only one dimension and but it's
it's not a cultural phenomenon I think
in most instances corruption is a very
economic activity it's created by the
institutions is created by the
incentives that that that that encourage
people to take bribes and to distort
things because of their benefits because
they know they can do so in reading with
impunity in terms of the geography I
think it's a very important question so
when we argue that it's not geography
what we are talking about isn't that you
know whether your your poland in the
1930s neighboring germany doesn't matter
of course it doesn't matter you cannot
tell polish history without mentioning
being squeezed between russia and and
and and in germany what we what we mean
is that there aren't some geographic
factors that have a direct effect on
your prosperity because you are between
mountains or because you don't have
access to rivers or because you have
this crop and not that crop that doesn't
that's not defining but of course
geography interacts with institutions
and if your neighbors are particularly
aggressive internationally that's going
to have an impact if you're if you're in
a war with your neighbors that's going
to have an in fact but that's not the
direct effect of geography but it's an
effect of geography that interacts with
political social international context
with the with the behavior the human and
economic social behavior of your
neighbors in that context and i think in
terms of the future of inclusive
institutions I think I I tend to be
optimistic as somebody else from earlier
on said I think breaking out of
extractive institutions is a very
difficult process but still many
countries have done it and many more
countries are trying I think Eastern
Europe is one area where we see a lot of
inclusive institutions taking root and
becoming stronger Latin America is
another place with after centuries of
inequities and instability I see we see
some of the strongest democracies emerge
in Latin America I think places such as
Mexico Brazil Chile are going through
difficult institutional building process
but it's sort of paying off and you see
that in a variety of
economic outcomes in the in the area so
I'll just stop there very well done
thank you
Doug asked for an orchestral summation I
think we've seen a virtuoso performance
that I'd like to thank Darren for really
providing just a incites to a brilliant
mind at work during thank you very very
much
and I'd like to think I like to thank
you Doug for really being a catalyst for
gauging all of us and I think a
conversation that could have gone on for
at least another hour thank you they
would need drinks if it did yes and and
thank all of you for coming here this
evening I hope you've enjoyed it i think
this has been an important conversation
on a very important topic i invite all
of you to come to the back of the room
there's coffee there and you can
continue the conversation with their own
if he's not too tired by now thank you
all very much
you